hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend
uh joined today by my stalwart Chums hey
Sona mosesian hi and of course uh Matt
Gourley you're a wonderkind Gorly I'll
say that why where's that coming from
well just that
we Babble and Bibble and um then
whenever I check out the podcast you you
just do a very lovely job you make it
all happen oh thanks you're the secret
sauce I'm gonna say that right now I'm
not alone there's Eduardo there's Adam
there's blay there's they really do
nothing you think about it I mean
Eduardo actively works against the pod
that's true I try to mute him every time
Eduardo I mean the number of times that
Eduardo has actively tried to remove my
voice from the podcast
is um stunning yeah I mean I I can't let
him fall on the sword that comes from
high up okay yeah that's from you the
biggest note on uh Conan O'Brien needs a
friend is Les Conan yeah we're hearing
that a lot across the board and that was
always the note on Late Night with Conan
O'Brien Conan and it's the Conan show
starring Conan Les Conan is what people
wanted and uh you got to give them what
they want also I think I add something
too thank you so much well you do Shona
you do and no I was about to say you you
are a wonderful part of the podcast I
was going to say it's amazing that you
can make it here because you have twin
boys you're a working mom and that's an
incredible thing but then there's part
of me that wants to take that compliment
away because you get so much help from
your family okay and I'm bitter about
that why are you bitter why are you
bitter I was unattended as a child I can
be here I roamed the forest no okay you
did not roam before you grew up in a
Suburban part yes Boston yes dark
forests on every side
of Newton no West Boylston
the dark frightening force of Natick
Wellesley I mean no one knows what
you're talking about exactly from Boston
yeah they're raised by The Blair Witch
or something well I'm tempered and then
you probably had it easy as a dad come
on give it to her no no no no no listen
there were six kids uh two parents both
of them off doing their own thing
working hard God bless them and you out
of your grandma wasn't your grandma
living with you and helping you out she
was just telling us watch out for those
Protestants
they'll get you at school I mean she was
from the Victorian area literally yeah
so she was always trying to get my
sisters to wear like uh a corset made of
whale bone
yeah one of the things my grandmother
would always say is don't sit in wet
grass or you'll get diarrhea what this
is the kinds of things wait a minute so
wait a minute wait a minute
I love my grandmother her name was
Maddie but I don't you know
I'm just curious on the logic of that is
it that the the wetness from the grass
is seeping in and infecting there is no
logic well yeah what are you doing
there's no logic you know I can't have
shoes flipped upside down or it'll throw
off my whole life like that's what I've
been told like by your parents if you
store shoes it can't be upside down so I
never put that's a Superstition that you
heard yeah what other superstitions do
you have in your family God there's so
many you can't have any dirty dishes in
the sink at the end of the day they all
have to be clean and put away well
that's not a that's that's just called
just a manipulation
it just there's anything there's like
you're tying up Loose Ends like you know
purse straps can't be in knots or shoes
shoes
because it's a bad energy it's bad
energy my family was like don't touch
the fire it's hot yeah because you came
from a long line of sensible folk
Protestant but what does that mean mine
people are not sensible oh oh come on
Sony you know they're not they're not
sensible people and neither are mine
yeah but you don't come from sensible
people you don't sit in wet grass though
even today probably because you think
you'll get diarrhea no there's a party
that kind of believes it and when you do
get diarrhea do you think to yourself
did I sit in wet grass today and guess
what every time I have I went to a wet
grass Festival I was on the toilet for
nine years after that I know that is the
diarrhea Festival yeah
well I didn't know it by that name it
says it in parentheses underneath I see
wet grass Festival now serving diarrhea
um listen
uh providing diarrhea since 1908. I'm
probably uh one of the people that my
parents got to look after us kids while
they were away was this woman
um I think she was from Prince Edward
Island and she uh you know had rural
customs and traditions I said a word
that wasn't even that bad like crud or
what is his crud she took me to the
bathroom on the second floor of our
house and took out a bar of Dial soap
and washed my mouth out with soap oh and
I don't think that's happened to anybody
in my generation I had my mouth you had
your mouth that my grandma washed my
mouth oh she did okay well then I give I
I it's it's and you know what I remember
really clearly like this is a punishment
that that goes back a hundred years it's
a dickensian punishment
um I remember at her she's rubbing no
listen this is me
laugh on camera right I know I'm on
camera this is what happened show me
with both hands here's the well if you
insist so the soap
here's the problem how do you mime
anything like getting your wash your
mouth washed out with soap come on and
not invoke hold it like this no because
I'm telling you what she did I'm pretty
sure it was so oh god oh no oh what was
this
pressed memory
oh that was no lady so anyway
I'm sorry I'm realizing all these things
right now
oh my God this took such a dark
experience anyway what I remember is I
don't know if you had the same
experience the soap bar was going
vigorously in and out of my mouth
imagine bar of soap this is not the
dimensions of a [ __ ]
but what I remember is
everyone here is losing it what I
remember is the soap caking up on the
back of my front teeth the punishment
that keeps on punishing yes you taste it
for days afterwards and when I'd hiccup
a bubble would come out yeah yeah and
this isn't the days of like you know
Ivory artisanal soaps this is like Irish
Spring that tastes really good I would
have killed for Irish Spring me too
they're little bits of bits of beef and
lamb in there the Irish know how to make
a soap God damn it no I'm telling you
that that's how I grew up and so I think
sometimes I become angry Sona when I see
how much you're getting all this great
help from your parents you did come in a
little angry today and I think your way
of releasing your anger is just to [ __ ]
[ __ ] on me that's terrible it's been
what you do it's been my job security
it's fine I get it your father has that
amazing mustache and he's taking such
good care of your boys as is your uh
lovely mother um yeah and you've got all
these cousins and everyone comes from
the neighborhood and they all hold the
baby you've yet to hold your own
children believe you begrudges she had
twins she's a working mom with twins and
you're begrudging her getting help you
exactly exactly I resent it go get some
soap let's watch it I resent it and
please make sure it's Irish Spring and
also get some [ __ ] yeah
I remember it was [ __ ] shake for a short
time oh that makes more sense for a
short time a dial was making a a dildo
shaped soap Yes and this is around 1970
then they did it look it was a failed
experiment it was 1973. no because he's
an Irish swing well then they switched
to Irish swing that's right yeah and
then
[Music]
Irish swing I like to wash my mouth
every day in and out and in and out
what's the old Irish
this is stupid and uh my apologies to
people in the soap industry
anyone who's had been triggered by their
mouth being watched out with soap or uh
fellating uh soapy caught here we go